the home of some of the world's largest
and oldest sequoia trees will reopen to
the public tomorrow for the first time
in three years some of the trees in
Yosemite s Mariposa Grove have been
growing for close to 2,000 years there's
some of the oldest living things on
earth but after decades of visitors and
their cars the Grove of more than 500
sequoias was in danger of being loved to
death only on CBS this morning John
Blackstone has a preview of the restored
Grove before today's official
ribbon-cutting
it would seem hard to improve on the
grandeur of Yosemite National Park a
place that attracts about 4 million
visitors a year but for 3 years one of
the parks natural wonders has been
closed to the public well it underwent a
makeover to provide a better view of
giant sequoias trees that can grow more
than 250 feet tall here in Yosemite
National Park the Mariposa Grove has
trees so big it's hard to fit them all
in our picture but a 40 million dollar
restoration project is making it better
than ever to see these trees in person
completely restored and it's just a more
tranquil and have a more serene
experience freak Dean is president of
the assembly Conservancy a nonprofit
that raised twenty million dollars for
the restoration of the grove
the National Park Service put in another
twenty million how is this different
than what was here four years ago well
where we're standing right now there was
a diesel fuel station for the trams and
so now what you have is the first view
you get as you see it framed by two or
three giant sequoia trees the goal was
to take out many modern additions
returning the Grove to a more natural
state removing pavement and parking lots
restoring streams and wetlands and
minimizing the damage from cars and
people getting too close you can see
that people have come up to this tree
before and feel the bark and maybe pull
a strip of bark off so if we have
thousands of people coming to visit the
Grove we just can't allow people to come
up and touch the trees anymore sue
Beatty a restoration ecologist with the
National Park Service helps plan the
makeover including new fence
to protect the trees bark from too many
hands and raised walkways to protect the
roots from too many feet all those
footsteps would compact the soil around
those trees and the roots are very
shallow so if you compact that soil
they're not able to grab those the water
and nutrients that they need so this has
always been a an attraction for yes yes
even dead trees like one called the
fallen monarch drew early tourists to
the Mariposa Grove President William
Howard Taft wrote a buggy through the
California tunnel tree Theodore
Roosevelt stood under one called the
grizzly giant President Lincoln never
saw the Sequoias in person but he
recognized their value the law that
Abraham Lincoln signed back in June of
1864 established Yosemite Valley and
their Mariposa Grove of giant sequoias
so even back in the midst of our
country's civil war we realized that
America maybe even the world would be a
better place if you so many Valley and
the Mariposa Grove was protected the
latest steps in that protection were
being completed just in time for today's
ribbon-cutting
but while workers were taking care of
details on the ground visitors will be
looking up way up for CBS this morning
John Blackstone and the Mariposa Grove
Yosemite National Park that is a place
I've never been and would really love to
go I've been there and actually touched
the trees it never occurred to me we
were hurting the trees you can't help
but touch it but yeah when you're that
close to because we know better when
you're in the presence of those trees
you can feel it in your bones really can
hug days that you were a tree hugger
know